[Music]
yesterday was a day that we all knew
would come sometime
but in our hearts of hearts we hoped
never would
[Music]
queen elizabeth ii
was the rock on which modern britain was
built
for the vast majority of us it feels
impossible to imagine a briton without
her
[Music]
millions of us are trying to understand
why we are feeling this deep
and personal and almost familial
sense
of loss
[Music]
the british people are preparing to bid
a final farewell to queen elizabeth ii
the country's longest serving sovereign
and a single common reference point for
all of us
and to some the person that most bound
our sense of national identity
[Music]
it's been more than 70 years since
britain has seen anything like this
a country saying goodbye to one monarch
while also meeting the next
queen elizabeth was a life well lived
a promise with destiny kept
and she is mourned most deeply in her
passing
that promise of lifelong service
i renew to all today
as her coffin makes its last long
journey to london the new king makes his
first visits as monarch to his new
kingdom
i'm following him to all four corners of
the uk as he prepares to bury his mother
[Music]
the queen was often described as a
figure of stability and comfort in
uncertain times
but will i find a country which can find
that same reassurance in him
[Music]
[Applause]
i was incredibly dignified
amazing to see so many thousands of
people go completely silent
as the procession went past
she's one of one of the icons in the
country
and she's she's scottish you know what i
mean i think
queenie scots that's where she get calls
didn't she but moral or second home
do you think king charles can
maintain that level of affection
um that's i don't think so i don't think
i don't think he'll have well he's not
gonna have the rain that she did and
he's what maybe got 20 years at most i
would imagine i don't think he'll get
the same love and admiration as she did
what's she done for scotland what does
scottish people think of the queen um i
think it's probably mixed but from my
perspective i think she encourages unity
and she doesn't make any difference
relevant of your creative religion your
beliefs
do you think charles can do that to the
same degree to the same level of success
i'm not so sure that i would have
believed that beforehand but i think the
way in which he's portrayed himself and
certainly in the last week he's went up
really high in my estimations and i'm
behind the king definitely
do you think the new king will be as
popular
a monarch as his mother
no
not as popular he may be popular i'm
sure he will try to follow in her
footsteps these are very very big shoes
to follow uh no i don't think so i have
to say uh there's a checkered history
there for for charles and and camilla
but i wish him well but to follow his
mother is a very hard
royal routes here in scotland run deep
and often alongside strong nationalist
sentiment
there is a sense that the queen was
almost the glue that held
all the devolved nations together gave
us all a shared sense of of britishness
perhaps
will that now change under king charles
well i think we have to think about the
continuity of monarchy and it's the is
that always having a monarch that is
that beacon of stability
politics by its very nature is
short-lived but we take reassurance that
we will always have a monarch
but this the demise of this monarch
is clearly a
a big moment in history and one that
will take quite a lot of adjusting for
many many people until they feel settled
we've had so much change in a week we
saw a new prime minister and a new head
of state that's just extraordinary and
unheard of
and people are reeling from all the
challenges they're facing in their daily
life and i'm no different
[Music]
scottish independence isn't chiefly
motivated by republicanism but it is an
undercurrent
[Music]
without the queen as a unifying force
the movement will likely get stronger
[Music]
through all the years of her reign
the queen like so many generations of
our family before her
found in the hills of this land
and in the hearts of its people
a haven and a home
do you think scotland's
opinion of the monarchy will change now
the queen has died and charles has taken
the throne
well the position of scotland with
regard to the monarchy has been changing
the monarchy still has majority support
in scotland but rather less so than in
england that's been going on for the
last 30 or 40 years it's connected with
the independence question
on the other hand you have to separate
the position of the monarch from the
institution of monarchy and the late
queen was much more
popular than the institution itself so
we'll have to see how the new king fares
do you think
the king can unify the country in the
same way
that the queen did because it's quite
fractured isn't it the uk it is yeah i'm
not sure i'm not frankly sure he's
capable of doing that i hope he is i'd
like to see him do that that time will
tell if he can pull it together
when the announcement came to be queen
of died i was at the football it was
half time at the
hearts game
it was really interesting so we had a
minute silence that was spoiled by sort
of some people sort of anti-monarchy and
some people that were
sort of trying to sing the national
anthem and they were put down so i think
uh
yeah
i think it's a real sort of interesting
time that we're in
the scottish people are the first to say
goodbye to the queen
and to meet king charles close up
[Music]
queen elizabeth famously said that life
was full of first meetings and final
goodbyes
a coffin departs edinburgh in an raf
c-17 for the last time
[Music]
in northern ireland the king touches
down to mark his mother's passing
[Music]
here feelings towards the monarchy are
the most polarized of anywhere
[Music]
but this week the country's fraught
politics take a back seat
in the loyalist schankel area of belfast
solemn crowds gather to pay tribute
it's quite incredible the number of
flowers and flags and tributes that have
been left here
thank you mom your service is done says
that one what does that say in memory of
the people's queen
little 10 year old boy may flights of
angels sing the to thy rest
and they're still coming
we've always thought highly of the queen
she was absolutely amazing person will
never get anyone else like her
you must have been very sad when when
you heard that she passed away furry
sides uh
she had it here because uh it came very
sudden because she had
just welcomed uh
a new prime minister on the
bid one farewell and was very sad that
uh two days later should uh
pass but thankfully uh
surpassed uh
peacefully and has left a nice legacy
for us you know to remember by
a few streets away in the republican
area of falls road response to the
queen's death and the new monarch's
visit is more muted
do you have any
feelings towards the queen do you have
any sort of respect for her given given
what she achieved in her lifetime
um
well
i hope we better remorse in the sense of
it's someone's grandparent
but other than that no not really
that's
it
didn't really bring anything to yours in
this area
and is that the feeling
more widely do you think but bernie
there is yeah like there's
a lot of hardship hard times around here
nick during the troubles
and obviously all that
wasn't made easier by the royal family
so
we're kind of just getting normal all of
our day-to-day life nothing's changing
well it's wrong been done on that you
have to um
not say forgiven forgetful don't think
you'd ever forget things just has
happened
but it's a new day
a new day which belongs to king charles
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but underlying tensions endure despite
the show of unity
[Music]
[Applause]
royal supporters screamed and bust in
cheer his arrival to the royal residence
[Music]
inside he meets the vice president of
sinn fein a growing political force in
today's northern ireland and its largest
party
incredibly kind things that you've said
about me
well she played a great role here in
terms of reconciliation about my face so
it's the end of an era for sure
a handshake that is evidence of both
progress and uncertainty about what lies
ahead
[Music]
my mother felt deeply i know the
significance of the role she herself
played
in bringing together those whom history
had separated
and in extending a hand
to make possible the healing
of long-held hurts
now with that shining example before me
and with god's help
i take up my new duties resolved to seek
the welfare
of all the inhabitants of northern
ireland
northern ireland is a place where queen
elizabeth had a very personal influence
her reign was dotted with symbolic
interventions that only she could make
those gestures were hugely powerful just
in giving other people in northern
ireland permission
to step away from their historic views
perhaps their very entrenched ideologies
and start to reconcile one with another
[Music]
i think if you move forward to where we
are now michelle o'neill who's the
uh vice president of sinn fein and the
leader of shinto sinfina northern making
very heartfelt tributes to the queen and
sympathizing with the royal family these
are things that to me would have been
unthinkable
15 20 years ago they just wouldn't have
happened
so that shows how far we have come and
there is a there is clearly a
a level of maturity
in political discourse in northern
ireland now and on the island of ireland
that we haven't really seen in decades
and it's it's very refreshing to me
and it's something that has to be built
on now by king charles
what role
does king charles have in trying to
unify
the united kingdom
i'm not sure that his rule necessarily
is to promote
unionism but it is to i think show
that regardless of what the future holds
there is some kind of certainty and
stability at the center and i think that
that can be a hugely important role
[Music]
[Applause]
a crowd gathers outside saint anne's
cathedral captivated by the ceremony
inside the service has been lovely you
know i feel like you know seeing all
those presbyterian church of ireland
different ministers from across uh
different christian backgrounds is so
important especially northern ireland
and it's lovely to see the unity across
the political spectrum even those who
are opponents to the monarchy paying the
respect for the queen first of all i
would like to pay tribute
to the work that
our late majesty has done
for peace and reconciliation on this
island of ireland and between
our two islands
in fact
i think she should be
proclaimed
regina patches
queen of peace for what she has done
i'm quite sure
that king charles
will follow in the footsteps of his
mother
in time we'll see how much king charles
deviates from the queen's path but for
now his duty is to deliver his mother
over to her people
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the queen has arrived at her official
home for the last time
tomorrow her coffin will be handed over
to lyon state it will be a day of
pageantry and ceremony that has not been
seen in a lifetime
[Music]
thousands of people have filled the
streets of the capital to see the
queen's coffin an opportunity to see
history unfold before their eyes
[Music]
well this is incredible the number of
people here is unbelievable
i was here during the platinum jubilee
and the atmosphere is so different it's
um
i wouldn't say it somber or sad but it's
very quiet and i think
people are being genuinely
respectful
members of the armed forces here
people who look like they've come from
work
people of all ages actually youngsters
as well
when you had the horse riders standing
in fields connected and then the tractor
driver so everybody from every walk of
life has lined the route somewhere
and it is a very sad day but
charles is the man to take it forward
and i'm sure he will there's not a
single person in america not a
politician not a notable that i'd have
waited in the rain for hours to watch go
by so the fact that i'm an american
in the street in the rain waiting for
your queen to go by was
we don't have anything like this i mean
it's a connection to history that you
have that we we really don't and you
know i mean right now we're struggling
with our politics and
we don't have anything above it well
she's such a it's such a historical
figure a lady who's on the duty for such
a long time i follow england around the
world football and we always sing the
national anthem and it becomes quite uh
infectious
and so it's a it's a nice way of paying
respects seeing charles
i think he's got an epically challenging
job on his hands but he's well prepared
i think he'll be a great
[Music]
the lives and reigns of kings and queens
form an ark through britain's past
and at times like this it's like a page
is turning one error ending and another
just beginning
[Music]
[Music]
it's a really sad day but i'm
so privileged to be here
everyone's been incredibly respectful
haven't they yes so quiet yes
that that was um
i'm really glad about that she deserved
to have that respect and
yeah it was remarkably quiet wasn't it
that was quite something wasn't it it
was amazing i mean we all came here i
don't know these people but we all came
together today all from different parts
of the country had a little chat
beforehand and then a wave of silence
came towards us and it was just a calm
and it was a beautiful moment this the
sun came out look at the sun now
and just shone down and it was just it's
just so emotional we just we all had a
little tear and a hold of hands it was
like it was a lovely lovely thing to
witness i'm so glad i came i'm from
uganda myself and it's good for me to be
here as a black person as well just to
say
appreciate
that the love the kindness she's
brought to the commonwealth
and basically show my children you know
let them be part of the history around
here i think like it was like really
beautiful like how much respect everyone
pays attention to like the queen's stuff
and i think that of the queen was like a
really good leader to like the whole
country and like made people feel like
more
more happy and stuff about it but now
that she sadly died it's really like
upsetting and like upsetting everyone
but um she's she's in a safe place now
[Music]
the queen arrives in the palace of
westminster leaving a wake of emotions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here she stays for five days and nights
lying in state every minute kept company
by a constant stream of people from
different places generations and
cultures
for the new king his journey around the
country has only just begun
what do you think of king charles what
do you make of him can you carry on the
queen's work he definitely can he's been
brought up that way and you've got the
same morals as the queen so hopefully
yes
big shoes to fill though
very big shoes the felony is the queen
nobody else could walk in our steps
he has a lot of support in these crowds
but the challenge he faces is clear
no one can succeed the queen in the
imagination of the british public
for some people who've descended on
london this isn't about the history and
the pageantry
it's far more personal
you decided to do this rather than see
the procession
yes i think we felt we need to decide to
do one thing or the other because i
think if you did the procession and then
joined the queue
you would be here for days really i
think we've lost an enormous
figure
in our lives and in our country and it
will take
a very long time to come to terms with
that
but we already know there's been a
seamless handover
we still have a monarch
i think it's important for the uk
possibly some parts of the world maybe
the whole world you know momentous
occasion
talk me through how you're feeling what
sort of emotions have you got what's
going through your head got all the
tissues ready
like any of you pay respects you think
you might shed it's here i am you are
all ready
she is a magnificent woman of course and
i love this you know since i know
she was my mama in papa's first head of
the state
they are in sri lanka and she was head
of the state in siloam back in the days
since 1952 1952-72
so
this for my
mom and dad that's what i'm doing for
them
[Music]
and this is the queue they're standing
in
thousands of people stretching miles
through central london
that's thousands of individual journeys
to see the queen's coffin
these people will wait for hours for
their moment inside westminster hall
[Music]
[Music]
how did you find that
it was so moving inside i didn't expect
i didn't expect at all
i i was trying to hold my
emotion
i never get that kind emotional i never
cried so it was it was quite lovely to
see
what did you make of that
just gorgeous i think she's just a bit
speechless and i'm welling up as well
it's a very emotional day i think for
the country and i wait till monday
you know when the funeral is here
i think it would be
a whole country which will just
be grief stricken
so how was how was that experience
um
amazing very serene
and tranquil
beautiful and
yes so moving so moving
and worth all those hours queueing
absolutely
[Music]
me
hmm
[Music]
you